the wind is at our sails
the political winds are against these
people and the party that welcomes them
the democrat party
take the advantage press the advantage
don't give an inch republicans are
feeling emboldened right now there was
an ad that went viral yesterday
this is from a guy jerome davidson who's
running for congress in arizona
take a listen
democrats like to say that no one needs
an ar-15 for self-defense
that no one could possibly need all 30
rounds
but when this rifle is the only thing
standing between your family
[Music]
and a dozen angry democrats in clan
hoods
you just might need that semi-automatic
in all 30 rounds
[Music]
this is a really clever ad and it's it's
a clever ad
not just for the reasons that everyone
is talking about it's red meat yeah you
go get them you go yeah that's right
this is we're defending guns we're
calling democrats racist yeah baby this
is great it's not it's not just clever
for that reason
frankly i actually think the whole
democrats are the real racist line is a
little bit overused and the constant
hearkening back to the antebellum south
and and referring to the democrats as
the party of the clan sure it's true
democrats are the party of the clan but
it it seems a little cheap to me and
here's why it seems cheap to me
and it's actually why this ad is so
clever and it's why the ku klux klan is
a safe subject for this ad
the ku klux klan doesn't exist
practically speaking there is no such
thing as the ku klux klan there have
been multiple groups in u.s history that
have called themselves the ku klux klan
none of which exist today it's gone it's
a boogeyman it's not real
when you fear political violence in your
community or anywhere else in the
country
do you think it's going to come from the
ku klux klan from people wearing hoods
no of course not it'll it's going to
come from the left almost certainly but
it's going to come from antifa or it's
going to come from blm or it's going to
come from other left it's going to come
from ruth sent us or the other
anti-anti-pro
groups anti-pro-life pro-abortion groups
it's gonna it's gonna come from
left-wing militants but it's
it's not the clan
the reason this is such a clever ad is
that everybody hates the clan
it's a it's a totally unifying symbol
it's a symbol of an evil that isn't even
real anymore it does of a of a boogeyman
so people can unite around that it does
draw the historical connection between
the democrat party and the ku klux klan
it does point out that second amendment
is not is not some uh
buttress of white supremacy in the and
the patriarchy and the
republicans and the conservatives no
actually
vulnerable people minority groups or
women who are physically more vulnerable
than men they actually benefit much more
from the second amendment because it's
an equalizer
against mob against angry mobs that
might show up to your house or against
people who are physically bigger and
stronger than you so it's clever for
that reason it's a reminder too
of something that i've said for a year i
think this is the proof of something
that i've said for years now which is
that
today in america
our public discourse has become so
shallow that the the only way we can
talk about evil is as racism racism is
the not only the the greatest evil in
the country it's really the only evil
and so when we want to really attack
it's the worst thing you can be called
in america is to be called a racist and
so whenever we want to attack someone if
you really want to hit them you call
them a racist even when what they're
doing has nothing to do with race
republican democrats will accuse
republicans of racism for wanting to cut
taxes or wanting to reform schools or
wanting to save black babies when we
overrule roe v wade and we make it more
diff and pass pro-life laws and make it
more difficult to have abortions that
will disproportionately save black lives
it will increase the black and hispanic
portions of the population and somehow
the libs call that racist as well it's
the only way that we can view things and
the only way that we can view the
struggle between good and evil and
american history is through the lens of
the civil rights movement and that has
been true for a long time chris caldwell
wrote a very good book to this effect a
few years ago called the age of
entitlement after the civil rights act
and after the great society
that represented not merely some new law
that was being passed but it represented
a kind of revolution in america and in
the way that we think of ourselves and
so what's so brilliant about this ad is
that jerome davidson is plugging into
that
he's saying look this is what is going
to resonate
this is how americans view themselves so
i am going to put myself there it's the
same reason that candidates wave flags
wave the flag wrap yourself in the flag
is because we know that those symbols
resonate with people and in america
today
for everybody
the ku klux klan
is
one of one of if not the highest
representations of evil racism is evil
the two are synonymous and civil rights
is the struggle it is the struggle for
liberation right now text knowledge to
989898
i was wrong about the path inflation
would take i was not wrong i was totally
right but our treasury secretary janet
yellen was wrong and she admitted it
that's a quote from her she said there
have been unanticipated and large shocks
to the economy that have boosted energy
and food prices and supply bottlenecks
that have affected our economy badly but
at the time i didn't fully understand
didn't fully understand there you have
it
straight from the horse's mouth didn't
fully understand now
i know that right now you're probably
worried about affording basic
necessities in the months to come food
gas shelter but hey she didn't know
oopsie daisy not her fault right goes
without saying we cannot trust these
so-called authorities on economic policy
which is why you should invest at least
some of your money in gold and silver
with birch gold group
these are the guys that i trust you can
protect your savings from a highly
turbulent economy by diversifying your
401k or ira into physical gold text
knowles right now kowles to 989898 get
real advice from birch gold today text
knolls to 989898 to claim your free no
obligation info kit on protecting your
savings with gold
everyone's trying to apply
the black civil rights movement to their
own groups this was a strategy
undertaken by the left during the 1970s
they saw how effective civil rights was
for black people
he said okay we're going to use this for
hispanic people
we're going to use this for asian people
we're going to use this for women second
wave feminism
it never made any sense these black
people actually are a unique
circumstance in america the fact that
lots and lots of black people the
majority of black people who are in
america have some dissent from slavery
and that their ancestors brought over in
chains is different than any other group
hispanics can claim oppression the
italians and the irish i guess can claim
oppression the asians can claim
oppression but those groups chose to
come to america and for black people
it's different so it gives black people
and
i mean obviously they're black
immigrants from africa who came after
slavery but for black people as a group
that creates a unique historical
circumstance and groups like the ford
foundation and other left-wing
institutions decided they were going to
blur those distinctions and try to apply
the the ethos of civil rights to all of
these other groups and it worked pretty
well now even to the point that we're
talking about the civil rights against
oppression for
homosexuals or transgender as though
it's the same thing as breaking free
from chattel slavery and jim crow
it's the same thing now as breaking free
from your bounds of biology and
and uh dresses and stiletto heels so
buzzfeed you you understand that the
ellen page saga that has dominated our
public discourse for the past few days
the idea that ellen page this actress
now goes by the name elliot and doesn't
want to be called ellen anymore this
created a big stir on twitter
because now if you sit call ellen page
ellen you can be booted off it happened
to jordan peterson it happened to dave
rubin for even reporting on jordan
peterson well buzzfeed then came back
and said wait wait a second twitter you
violated your own rules against hate
speech because in your trending topics
bar you used the phrase helen helen
ellen page because people were talking
about ellen page ellen page trended but
according to your own rules ellen page
can't trend because that name this
actress's name is hate speech because
the actress doesn't want to go by ellen
anymore and then do you know what
twitter did because we're living all the
way through the looking glass in clown
world
twitter apologized and said you're right
we can't we can't allow
a woman's name to trend that woman's
name
is hate speech
what does this represent if ellen page
tomorrow
came out and said hey i'm ellen again do
you know what you know what's so crazy
they would have to get rid of elliot
because elliot would then become her
dead name they call it a dead name when
a person decides to pretend to be a
member of the opposite sex and change
his name and then the name that that
person had gone by for his entire life
goes away and you're not allowed to even
utter it anymore that's that's pretty
crazy right especially because they
could change the name back and then it's
the other one that goes away
what this represents is something much
bigger than transgenderism or even
sexual politics it represents
the left's broader rejection of the past
everything that came before is evil and
awful and oppressive we need to liberate
ourselves from the past
past is always evil the president is
always a crisis in the future is always
going to be a utopia just so long as you
give us a little bit more power that's
the pitch that the left makes and you
see it so clearly in the the idea of
dead naming even one's own personal past
even one's own
past identity
can no longer be acknowledged it's not
just tearing down statues
of old dead people it's not just even
rewriting the history books it's your
own past that now has to be completely
denied in what is a kind of
pseudo-religious sacrament in
christianity you have baptism where the
old the old man is washed away and you
and you now put on the garment of christ
and you have a new life in christ well
that's what you have in a perverse way
in a sacrilegious way through the
transgender coming out you cast off your
old name you cast off your old identity
and that is dead now and now you have
this new identity in sexual delusion it
runs really really deep it touches on
all of the bizarre
perverse eccentricities of leftism it
goes a lot deeper than just some actress
it's really weird i think it's turning a
lot of people off i think people are
waking up to how bizarre not just this
weird sexual ideology is but the entire
leftist agenda the wind is at our sales
i hope that ellen and elliot and all the
pages and all this weird and the bell
court theater and all this craziness i
hope it continues to trend all the way
to november press the advantage the wind
is at our sails if you enjoyed that
break from disinformation historical
revision and screaming about the end of
the world be sure to hit the subscribe
button so that you never miss another
video
[Music]
[Music]